we all make mistakes
you've probably heard these words before
usually their words people say when
they're trying to make you feel better
you've just said something a little
stupid maybe you tried to pay someone a
compliment and it came out really
awkward and now you're worried that you
might have offended them maybe you
carelessly gave away a secret that
wasn't yours to tell or maybe you lost
your temper and you said something you
didn't really mean something you regret
and now you're feeling guilty or
embarrassed and one of your friends
tries to comfort you by reminding you
that we've all been there don't worry
about it she says nobody is perfect we
all make mistakes and maybe hearing this
makes you feel better because it's true
nobody's perfect we all go around
talking to people all day every day and
every once in a while we're bound to say
the wrong thing no big deal but what if
our friend is wrong what if it is a big
deal what if our words actually matter
in today's reading from the New
Testament James starts his discussion of
the power of language by reminding us
that nobody's perfect all of us make
many mistakes he says but James is not
telling us this to comfort us he's
trying to make us uncomfortable he's
trying to make us think about our
tongues not as harmless floppy pink
flaps covered in taste buds but as
deadly instruments of devastating power
the tongue is a fire he tells us it is a
restless evil full of deadly poison
according to James our tongue steers our
whole body it guides our movement
through the world like the rudder of a
ship and if we let our tongues run away
with us we drift off course we poison
our friendships we start a forest fire
that we can't put out the very same
tongue that we use to praise God can be
used to curse people who are made in
God's image our words are like water
from a spring bubbling up deep within us
cool and refreshing or salty and
stinging our words are the sweet or
bitter fruit that we bear God use words
to speak the world into being God said
let there be light and there was light
but words can also plunge us into
darkness
I was thinking about the destructive
power of words last week during a long
conversation with one of my little
sisters when she was in elementary
school my brother and I were in high
school and to this day my little sister
vividly remembers how it felt to be
sitting at the dinner table every night
as my brother and I talked on and on
about all the big kids stuff that was
important to us and as a little kid she
could barely get a word in edgewise she
would start to say something that
mattered to her from her seven-year-old
perspective and we big kids would talk
over her or interrupt her or tease her
sometimes we laughed at her we didn't
really listen and for years she felt
frustrated and diminished and silenced
and as long as my sister and I live
whenever we talk to each other she will
remember somewhere in her soul what it
felt like to grow up feeling drowned out
by the sound of her siblings voices our
overwhelming words were a threat to her
developing sense of self and 20 years
later that hurt is still going
it can be painful and scary to think
about the damage that our words can do
especially if we're not sure how it can
be undone but James wants us to think
about it he wants us to confront the
power of our own language because he
knows that this power can be harnessed
for good God wants us to learn to
harness it for good but how the first
step is to stop thinking about our words
as less important than our actions and
to start thinking about words as one of
the most important things that we do
about 60 years ago an Oxford philosopher
named Jael Austin developed a new theory
of language instead of thinking about
speech and action as distinct things
where action is doing things and speech
is just talking about things Austin
reconceptualized speech as a kind of
action he developed a concept he called
speech acts statements that actually
make things happen in the real world and
he wrote a book called how to do things
with words that talked about how certain
kinds of sentences actually change the
world around us just by virtue of being
said a parent names a baby and that name
becomes the word that will follow her
all the days of her life a minister says
I now pronounce you wife and wife and
two women began a marriage together that
will last until one of them dies Jael
Austin didn't necessarily believe that
all speech was action but in a way it is
and James certainly thinks it is
thinking about our speech as real
consequential action is a first step in
learning how to wield our voices so much
of the time when we think that there's
nothing we can do in a situation there's
something we can say
and if we're thoughtful and creative and
a tune to God's Spirit we can discover a
way to say it I'm a writing teacher so I
spent a lot of my time thinking about
language and how it works and how it can
work better I'm always scribbling on
students drafts saying things like great
introduction or good use of imagery or
this sentence has no verb sometimes I
say I do not think that this word means
what you think it means lately in
English 120 I've been talking with my
students about how writers develop a
sense of voice how is it that we read a
few sentences from Joan Didion or James
Baldwin and we know instantly who is
talking to us and how can we as writers
develop a voice that is clear and
beautiful and distinctively our own how
can we choose words that draw our
readers in and give them pleasure and
leave them with the gift of new meaning
managing words on the page is a very
different thing than forming words with
our lungs and vocal cords and sending
them into the air but I think there are
some real similarities we all have these
god-given voices that we can use to say
anything and through thoughtful choices
and creativity and sensitivity to the
people we're in conversation with we can
develop our voices into the sound of
blessing yes we all make many mistakes
but we can all do a lot of good as well
our words are like a long poem dedicated
to God dedicated to each other our words
are a spoken word performance part
planned part improvised bubbling out of
the deep Brooks that's well within our
souls
and as we talk about our life and we
talk to the people in it we are helping
to tell our own story and the story of
those around us and the story of the God
who surrounds us all the God who spoke
us all into being who named us before
the foundations of the world and God has
called us to share in this work of
naming and storytelling and composing
poems of praise the creative and
consequential work of everyday
conversation and daily speech to put a
new spin on an old phrase if we want to
follow Jesus we can't just walk the walk
we have to talk the talk so think about
your tongue for a minute feel it sitting
there warm and alive in your mouth
sheath behind your teeth ready and
waiting it's going to get quite a
workout this week it's going to say all
kinds of things and the speech X it
performs can be sharp and shattering
like an axe or solid and strong and
constructive like bricks and mortar or
soft and cool like aloe vera lotion on a
sunburn what do you want to say this
week what things do you want to do with
your words
sometimes if you say yes to something
that you know is good but you're still a
little scared of your tongue can lead
you boldly into new adventures and
sometimes if you say notice something
that's wrong or unnecessary your tongue
can protect you or someone else right
now there is someone in your life to
whom you can say I love you a friend a
family member God and when you say it
their heart will begin to glow there is
someone in your life to whom you can say
I'm sorry or I forgive you and their
heart might begin to melt there is
someone in your life to whom you can say
I need some help and they will help you
and there is someone in your life you
don't even know yet who is going to be
one of your best friends who might just
need you to say hi this week say
something that you've been needing to
say for a long time weigh your words on
your tongue feel their power choose them
carefully and then send them out into
the world to do their work if you are
ever tongue-tied then you can sit in
silence and really listen to someone
else that's often the best gift you can
give the most loving thing that you can
do
and if you were ever alone with lots to
say but no one to say it to then pour
out your soul and complaint and
gratitude and petition and praise to god
I'll close with a short New Year's
prayer that someone taught me a long
time ago it's a good prayer for the
beginning of a new school year let us
pray
Jesus you are the first word I utter in
the new year may your name forever be
laughter in my mouth and when I come to
die may Jesus also be my last word amen